if you can dodge a wrench you can dodge
a ball
what the ending to greed island is
a conclusion that while sudden efficient
and clever
leans heavily on the dynamics that make
this arc specifically
work fundamentally it's in my view one
of the best endings the series itself
has ever delivered and yet
why was i left largely unsatisfied and
disappointed by the greed island arc
as a whole i mean it certainly didn't
have anything to do with the flawless
inclusion of mankind's greatest pastime
dodgeball
and so if it's not that then what was it
i mean it's filled with some of my
favorite shonen scene types and i'd even
go out on a limb and say that this arc
has my favorite scenes from the series
however where i think it fails perhaps
lies with hunter hunter's greatest
weakness
and a basic failure to utilize the
established setting
appropriately i found this act to be
utterly fascinating and i can't wait to
discuss
what i thought about it with you here
today so sit back
grab your joystation controllers and pay
attention as i break down why greed
island works so well
and why i feel it failed greater than
perhaps any other arc
in the series and yes i will also make
it my mission to fill this video with as
many dodgeball movie references
as is humanly possible
[Music]
greed island employs terrific ideas and
scenes however they're almost always
either at odds with the game world or
totally unreliant on the world to
function thus making the greater world
feel
superfluous in a sense on a broad level
the game itself
does motivate gone and kilauea to reach
its ending however despite this
during practically every event in this
arc that i enjoyed the events were
not made better by the presence of the
game and
in some cases actually were hurt by it
the interpersonal conversations between
gon and kilauea the encounter with
biscuit gone and killer was training for
months
the dodgeball game krolow and hisoka's
investment in each other
all of these elements are interesting
not because of the game but
in spite of it none of these scenes
derive entertainment value from the
medium of the game they are presented
in isolation they would be just as
interesting outside of the game free of
its rules and there could even be an
argument that they might be more
interesting then now
that's not to say that this story
doesn't make use of the game world at
all to directly
impact the story it does but those
moments are sort of few and far between
with the ending facilitating easily the
best usage of its world
it's an ending that quite literally
couldn't have happened in any other
setting
had the world not existed in other words
if the game world didn't exist then
neither would this ending be possible
and thus in addition to many other
components that make up this conclusion
it is in my opinion
the best ending an arc has received in
this entire story so far
it's a remarkable conclusion one filled
with suspense surprise
insight and above all else clever
writing that i'll be diving into in
greater detail in a little while but the
point i want
to make is that whenever takashi made
use of the game's world to create plot
points or
to drive the story forward it put a
smile on my face
and similarly every time he failed to
reliably or meaningfully connect the
world he wrote to the story or set
pieces therein
i was left deeply unsatisfied asking
myself
what's the point of us spending all of
this time in this game doing these
things when we could do all of these
things
outside of this game anyway it just
feels like a giant waiting period
to perhaps better understand this
concept i'd like to draw your attention
firstly to a film i dislike
greatly illumination animations 2016
film entitled
sing this film is the perfect example of
a story that does
absolutely nothing to justify or make
use of its setting to drive the plot
forward
why are all the characters animals well
just because i guess
it's vapid lacks meaning and therefore
the film feels that much less
interesting as a result you could very
easily switch out every character in
this film for human beings and the
story's narrative doesn't lose
anything meaningful however if you
thoughtfully compose a story around
these visuals and characters you get
something like
disney's 2015 film zootopia not only
does the decision to fill this cast with
animals impact the progression of the
story it's the very foundation of the
script
on a fundamental level the story of
zootopia cannot work
without the characters being animals
this is why this film works and why
sing in my opinion failed instead of
greed island's mechanics acting as the
foundation for which to build your story
upon
it instead acted as some sort of
middleman making it so
so much more boring than it could have
been had tagashi committed to the
material more or
perhaps reorganized the story
foundationally the story of the greed
island arc isn't necessarily
about the game or what the game offers
necessarily but instead it's about
what hunter hunter is about gone looking
for his father jing now i can only speak
for myself but i would imagine that
jing's involvement with the game and the
information we garner from this game
is predominantly what most of us are
waiting for during this arc
and not for what the game will do next
instead the game acts as something that
stops us from reaching our goal of
learning more about jing
in other words it's sort of a waiting
room a waiting room and
almost nothing more there are some fun
elements in this waiting room but none
that would be unique to this setting
necessarily
the hunter exams were unique to the
first arc and those were the short-term
goals directly attached to it the zoldic
family arc focused on learning more
about kilowatt's broader family as well
as rescuing him from them and directly
made full use of that setting and those
elements
in addition to that it was so short it
barely counted as an arc heaven's arena
is a tournament setting and as a result
the building itself which the ark is
named after
fundamentally structures the entire
story surrounding that
arc as well as it facilitating the
arrival of men
into the greater world and york new city
was about kurapika's struggle and
vengeance
while gone learned a considerable amount
about his father
all the while pushing towards a common
conclusion every arc got us closer to
this next ultimate goal which was
jing but greed island begins with jing
saying
that he won't find him there and forgone
to just have fun
trying to win and get out that's it
naturally more comes from this at the
end which is why i think it's the best
ending this series has produced but from
a structure standpoint
unlike heaven's arena that felt very
distinct with a built-in structure
because greed island is an open world
card game the rules we are required to
learn the dozens of characters we are
expected to keep track of and the open
world
open-ended nature of this game only
served to bore me on occasion and
only provided a loose or flimsy
structure to its story at best
similar to saying all of my favorite
scenes in this story could have come
from
any of the other arcs and made just as
much sense in those with the same sort
of build up and perhaps even more
tension and even saying that there were
elements that i adored in the first half
but once the ending wrapped up
of this arc i realized it had little to
no impact on the overall story
one of my favorite scenes from the first
half of this tale came from the phantom
troops portion of it through their
escapades and adventures we learned the
game
isn't what the public thinks it is and
that produced at least for me a ton of
intrigue and curiosity over how this
might play into the greater story and
the real world but
in the end it didn't contribute much of
anything other than some context
it didn't affect the greater story or
its progression in any meaningful way
the best piece of information to come
from this scene was
razer this is the section and antagonist
which most fans can agree is the best
part of this arc the bomber had some
upsides absolutely and i will be talking
about him a little later but razer
whether togashi intended him to be or
not was by far the most intriguing
aspect of this tale
despite that revelation from the phantom
troop not necessarily going anywhere
significant
the discovery of a particular character
called razer definitely raised a few
eyebrows his direct association with
jing the main goal of this entire story
by default made him massively
interesting as an individual on his own
to me
but now that he stands between gon and
everyone from getting their hands on a
card the bombers don't have yet
this mission suddenly became exciting
finally we get to strip away all of the
unnecessarily convoluted game mechanics
in lieu of the best part of this entire
arc
gone's team versus his in a number of
interesting sports or
competitions the first try it didn't go
so well but you know what that's okay
because now we can recruit the best the
world has to offer like
hisoka who with his hair down in the
manga looks just like light yagami from
death note
if he had a proclivity for small
children i mean let's be real here
the scene where hisoka decides to join
the boys is the most screwed up thing i
think i've ever read in a manga
whether it be the paneling and speech
bubble placement implying that he's
getting an erection
thanks to their presence or whether it
be the overtly creepy leering at their
asses
this scene made me feel all sorts of
uncomfortable forced me to ask the
question
why though once gone killer when
everyone were satisfied with their new
team and reapplied to play against razer
and his goons
something wonderful came to my attention
they are playing dodgeball
it's a bold strategy cotton let's see if
it pays off for them having come to the
realization that the bomber effectively
forced them all to engage in an 8-v
a dodgeball match for all the marbles
i'm inclined to say that despite all the
bad things i will no doubt say about him
later
he is for the duration of this fantastic
sports game
the greatest villain in all of fiction
for facilitating this
but all is not as it seems in this crazy
world of hunter hunter dodgeball because
the rules are slightly different and i
wasn't prepared to have
all of patches of houlihan's rules
thrown out in favor of some brand new
ones but
i quickly found my footing here and all
jokes aside this dodgeball game is one
of the most shonen performances i think
this arcane maybe even this series has
ever done and
i'm here for it right off the bat
takashi does a great job with
establishing razer as both dominant and
ruthless whenever we get characters that
are designed like this
with that sort of face juxtaposing them
with some vile actions like killing
someone while smiling is
always effective and unsettling between
the two teams it's clear who we're
rooting for
and systematically we feel the tension
rise as one after another
guns team falters and loses member after
member
[Music]
population you bro this dodgeball match
absolutely
raises guns standing among the rest of
the cast where the others like biscuit
and kilauea were willing to concede or
take a dirty victory
gone straight up refuses to accept
anything other than an absolute
dominant performance in victory his
tenacity his decisiveness his leadership
and his toughness are all on full
display here despite being outmatched
and knocked out once before
not only is he willing and determined
but he's confident in his own power and
ability and
he's got a plan and while killer and
hisoka are apprehensive at first
they backed this little spiky-haired kid
when it mattered furthermore what
impressed me the most about this scene
wasn't necessarily the hype action and
stakes it wasn't the amazing utilization
of guns new technique even but instead
it was the use of all of those
components
to distract from the best save i've ever
seen
a series deliver moments after gone hits
the dodgeball with everything he's got
razer despite guns enormous efforts
deflects the ball
into the air still in play razer
confidently seems to be safe with it
floating right above his head on his
half of the court when
bungee gum contains the properties of
both rubber and
gum you see oh my god he did it he said
the thing
hisoka is the friggin mad light of the
series and he saved this team in a way
that i
should have seen coming but never did
this was unbelievably satisfying i'm
even tempted to forgive him for the
weird stuff that he did in the earlier
parts of the story and speaking of
earlier earlier in this video i spoke a
little bit about making use of your
setting characters and themes and if you
look at the three best moments from this
dodgeball event the moment with ahsoka
the catch and end of the match you'll
notice that all of those
exchanges are great because they utilize
every one of the three players
gone kilauea and hisoka's techniques
respectively in addition to all of that
we have scenes like the catch which
flaunts tagashi's artistry beautifully
strong poses fantastic paneling and
gripping narrative structure
i swear these chapters are by far the
most impressive part of the arc save for
perhaps the very end with the conclusion
of the contest proving that sky is the
limit for gone when it comes to what
he's capable of
and boy do we get reminded of that later
all this time he's trying to prove to
himself and to everyone else that he
deserves to be his father's son
and funnily enough it's that very aspect
that created some serious wounds on
kilauea who while being desperate to
help gone in any way that he could
sacrificed his own hands for the victory
gone took some
savage hits during the battle but
kilowatt sustained what was
at that time possibly permanent hand
damage
and while i was watching this unfold and
that line about it maybe never returning
to normal was thrown around
i sincerely thought this could be a
scare he'll have to carry around with
him for the rest of his life a constant
reminder of how dangerous and careless
gun can be
when he gets headstrong over a
particular course of action numerous
times in the story gone throws caution
to the wind and places his friends in
unnecessary danger that sort of behavior
shouldn't be okay and while he
acknowledges it and apologizes i thought
this consequence of the match might be
something significant thematically
before we dive into that we need to talk
about another game
rage shadow legends who have kindly
sponsored today's video
if this is your first time touching the
internet and you somehow don't know what
rage shadow legends is
listen close because papa mark has some
words of wisdom here first up
click the handy dandy link in the
description to download the game it's on
all major platforms and pc
and let me take you on a journey i've
been playing around with raid a little
while now and i've grown quite attached
to some of the more
extra looking champions to say the least
ccf flametongue
in particular has been a real joy to use
i mean
her name is flame tongue and she looks
like
this she can obliterate the enemy team
with hp burn debuffs and
heal her teammates she's basically
perfect but hey
maybe you need more anger in your life
like i do in that case
there's brachus the shifter the badass
looking wolf who just doesn't stop
hating i guess the man's skill attack
hits six times and he can also heal
himself upon contact he's also great for
newbies too if his hp
falls below 40 percent his damage goes
up by the same amount and if you die
well it's even crazier because he gets
up and gets a free turn to try and
finish off his enemy it's a real
testament to the game's accessibility
and breadth of content this month alone
raids released 11 new champions 200 new
missions with legendary champion rewards
and what's more is they've added five
new levels to almost every single one of
the dungeons in the game that's an
incredible amount to add in just one
month
it's a bunch of fun so if it sounds like
it's up your alley make sure to use my
link down below so you can summon some
of the awesome champions i've just
mentioned
just click the link in the description
and i will see you in game
[Music]
i do not like how immediately after the
epic dodgeball match with someone
directly tied to the main goal of the
story the stakes immediately
plummet and shrink as we go back to
playing the game again
and let me make something perfectly
clear i am totally on board with wanting
to like this game i really am
but when we switch from what was once
awesome to now going back to
dual disc card collecting things i can't
help but
feel a little deflated and unfortunately
for the villain i didn't find him to be
entertaining
either we don't know much of anything
about him and he isn't really all that
impressive
he did one thing in the entire story
that i thought was noteworthy and
since then has done little else apart
from wait for the plot to come back
around to him whenever it gets off of
something
unfortunately more interesting with that
said however there's a decent effort on
behalf of tagashi to establish these
bombers as
the villains of this game by contrasting
them heavily with gon kilauea's
playstyle
while they are on top of the world
riding high with almost all of the cards
the feud that they are missing highlight
the difference and establish them as the
villains of this story
in storytelling contrast is one of the
most important elements or tools in a
writer's toolkit to achieve a desired
effect
honestly i could write an entire video
about how contrast and anticipation are
one of the most important things in
story writing but in short
in order to bolster our support for gone
and our distaste for the villains we are
shown two examples of their behavior
literally
side by side the villains swindled their
way into getting more cards from a deal
and gun quite literally uses one of his
own cards he recently acquired that
is valuable to help out people he met a
long time ago
in the story people who didn't give him
anything in return for his prior
kindness
but he thought of them when he got this
card and that speaks for something
and now as a result of that kindness has
a card achieved in a way
the bomber would never have thought of
they gained this card because they are
good people
and that's the difference between the
two of them a card the bomber now needs
represents the good nature in gone and
his friends interestingly during my time
in greed island i think i've better come
to terms with
what makes takashi great and where i
think his weaknesses might be as a
writer
now obviously this is just speculation
and shouldn't be taken too seriously i
mean take it with a grain of salt but
during and after my one piece review
hunter hunter was a series i was
recommended time and time again with
people saying stuff like
if you like one piece you'll love hunter
hunter and perhaps incorrectly i
interpreted that as
hunter hunter is similar to or like one
piece and
right now i can confidently say that
those two series are
viciously different so much so that i
genuinely think that dragon ball has
more in common with one piece than
hunter hunter does
take for example this scene from hunter
hunter in chapter 170 the bomber and his
team are desperate and therefore attack
a passerby to see if they can find
anything out about their pursuer's
location this interaction serves two
functions to help us understand
what the bomber is planning and to show
us how evil he can be and i think it
failed in the latter area to a
certain extent it was effective but
maybe not as effective as it could have
been and this is where the difference
between hunter hunter and one piece
are the most pronounced i think if oda
handled a scene like this the character
that was ambushed would have been a
character endeared to us to a moderate
extent earlier in the story with his
altruistic goals cleared to us
as readers prior to this interaction and
in the eventual encounter oda would put
this man through terror to make us hate
this bomber character all the more
before he goes too far
and really becomes despicable this is
precisely why characters like arlong are
so nefarious and
evil to us as viewers he directly
impacts and impedes the progress and
happiness
of a character like nami that we already
know about that's how i would envision
one piece to handle that scene
personally and the difference comes from
structure and willingness to let a
moment breathe this encounter in hunter
hunter takes place
over the course of two pages and all we
know about this person
is that he wants to go home furthermore
the actions the bomber takes
on him were twisted and hardly worse
than what he's already done before now
that's not to say that i don't think
hunter hunter is similar to one piece in
some
ways it's definitely emotionally rich
though i will say it is much more subtle
and in a way
less willing to embrace the emotion of a
certain scene like one piece wants to
now i'm not sure if that's a bad thing
or not it's pretty early days yet in
hunter hunter and in fact it could be
seen as a good thing hunter hunter is a
much more gritty and realistic world
than one piece and
when it plays into those strengths it
hits like a train
the final fight between going kilauea
and biscuit versus the bombers
was not only a nail-biting affair but
for me facilitated the single greatest
ending the series has ever seen
and the best part about it is that it
utilized and made necessary the rules of
the game
in order to fend off these bombers to
buy time for golden kilowatt to heal and
prepare the rules of the game and the
mechanics of it are used to full effect
and in interesting strategic ways
as they become the focus of the
narrative for some time
counting how many accompany cards they
have as well as stalking out places to
replenish the supply
this very much feels like a tense and
realistic depiction of the struggles one
might find in the real world if they
were to play this game what's more is
when the action does
reach fever pitch and gone does finally
go head to head against the bomber the
decisions made visually with the
implementation of gore makes it
immediately memorable while also
reinforcing the psychotic tendencies
gon possesses and how he's developed a
pride in himself over the course of this
story i'm not sure i'm a fan of the
latter from a moral standpoint but
narratively it's really solid
considering the way gone is developing
once again the way gone utilizes the
rules and the cards at his disposal
along with some clever planning and
thinking with his nan yielded one of the
best hand to hand or hand to stub
contest that this story has thrown my
way yet
with even the serial killer bomber guy
remarking at how crazy gone seems to be
acting and
he is of the three battles that
transpire here gonz
is the most significant from a plot
standpoint but that's not to say that
the others don't have something to offer
too
killer's battle is standard kilowatt
affair cam cool
collected and with a ton of great action
paneling biscuit
on the other hand had something else to
offer
and that's when the prince realized that
when you grab a bull
by the horns sometimes
he'll take you for a ride
now this is cool and all but it makes me
wonder if there are smaller people out
there like notaro who can
enhance their bodies maybe he's hiding
his true statue or something or
maybe there are people out there with
the right mastery that can enhance their
bodies to much
more hulking proportions it's food for
thought for sure
when gone and everyone win the day and
they get to fully heal themselves which
unfortunately includes killua's hands
and i was a little disappointed about
that
i was worried that because of these
status healing cards that there would be
literally no consequences from this game
nothing gained nothing earned beyond yet
more strength i mean
even biscuit a character that we met in
this story someone that eventually felt
like a natural and fun part of the group
eventually fell away and left abruptly
but these worries were non-founded and
that's when gong got to experience the
end of the game alone
and chose the ending for everyone and
not just himself he goes on to celebrate
and bring back the three cards into the
real world to use and the cards he chose
were
man they were just ingenious leading me
to come to the conclusion that gone is
the single most intelligent character in
all of hunter hunter that i've seen
i don't think i would have in a million
years thought to use the cards in this
way and it was all built off of gone's
primary motivation
to find his father hypothesizing that
jing was the first person he ever
encountered in the game when he was a
child was a master stroke all the
necessary cards were already explained
to us all the necklace mechanics and the
means of entering and re-entering the
game
are now common knowledge but it's that
awareness and combination with his
lifetime contact list that really
wouldn't be over now gon and killuas
seem to be certain that they can fly
directly to jing in my mind i was
convinced that they've done it this
ingenious galaxy brain play that could
only have happened in this arc with this
game and it had me at the edge of my
seat as i turned the page to see where
the boys had been transported to
oh hello mr chapter one
[Music]
it's kite in my mind the first thing i
thought about was how confusing a reveal
like this might have been to those of
you that have watched the 2011 anime
first but
once that set in we got this scene seems
like
jing had been watching the entire time
and what's more he judges gone harshly
for relying
and or wanting his friends around god
just what an insufferable jerk
i mean i really don't like him and you
know what the exciting part is
next week i'll be starting my coverage
on the chimera and
arc i literally can't wait i'm gonna go
read now things are getting crazy so see
you all next week guys thanks for
[Music]
watching
you